all right well nascar is in town this
weekend and it will be driver jimmy
johnson's final race at the las vegas
motor speedway as he retires from the
sport
johnson teamed up with danny coker owner
of counts customs for a special paint
scheme unveiled for this weekend's race
mercedes talked to both of them for
about the collaboration
yeah two guys that love to drive fast
collaborating
to create this new paint scheme for a
living legend first of all
jimmy let's talk to you your final
season
how has it been for you just with the
pandemic and everything going on
what has this been like it is really
weird
but i'm very thankful that our sport has
been able to go back to work
and it really appears like we'll make it
through the end of the season and
be able to crown a champion and all of
those things so um
you know again not not the year i dialed
up in my mind but we're making the most
of it as we go on
danny you helped create this paint
scheme for jimmy tell us a little bit
about
how you collaborated on this meeting
jimmy's just been
an amazing honor for me it really has
been so to be able to work
with jimmy and ally and hendrick on on
this car
is it's mind-blowing to me being
able to present the look of this vehicle
to a man who gets it he totally
understands
what i was going for on this and i think
the car just came out gorgeous
but for me the key was to make first
jimmy happy
uh was to make hendrick motorsports
happy was to make
ally happy and the key is making the
fans
happy and jimmy's been doing that for
years
so i wanted to make sure that this car
made everybody happy
and i believe we we pulled that off uh
have you
two actually been able to collaborate in
person yet or are you going to be at the
race this weekend danny to present this
to jimmy we're actually in the same room
right now jimmy's just over here
[Laughter]
we've actually never been in the same
room together at least we were so close
to being able to pull it off and then
they
pulled the plug on people at the track
so we had big
big hopes for this weekend sadly that's
all kind of washed out i want to do a
quick thing here before we let you go
um and see how quick you are on your
feet it's a little
it's a quick little game called four
second rule okay so i'm gonna give you
guys each a category and you have four
seconds to name
three items in this category okay three
three things you always see in the
garage
um my car uh tools
uh and the trash can
okay jimmy three things you always see
in the pits go
fuel can tires air wrench danny
three american-made car brands go
oh chevy ford uh chrysler jimmy three
places you love to go in las vegas
go race track
race track race chart
all right last one danny three of
jimmy's competitors
go oh my lord uh you've got
uh oh jeez you're gonna you're gonna
kill me here as far as i'm concerned
jimmy has no combat that's where i was
going with this
there we here we go